so what makes a  joker like you want to join the united  states army for  this guy had a face like death and every  other word out of his mouth was joker  god damn joker  uh well i just been seeing on the news  you know that there are kids dying over  there  you know guys from cleveland who are my  age  just trying to do something good and  here i am feeling sorry for myself  because my girlfriend broke up with me  damn she broke your heart  you searching for that gold in the  gutter a sense of purpose  right yeah  a sense of purpose god damn  tell you about purpose i like him i was  too easy  he knew he had me and so by the next day  i was sworn in against all enemies  foreign and domestic foreign and  domestic  you